do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's odd ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to take the time to
focus entirely on what looks to be an
incredible battle in Winterfell there is
a lot of new information about this
battle that I would like to cover
because it does give us some insight
into what it took to make this battle
come to life not only did we get some
glimpses of this in the new trailer but
Entertainment Weekly released a cover
story that went in a great detail about
this battle hopefully some of you find
this to be as interesting as I did I
don't want to read the entire article
from Entertainment Weekly but I would
like to discuss certain sections of it
you can find the link down below if you
would like to read the entire thing for
yourself now the first thing I want to
do is just kind of set the stage for the
battle in Winterfell I want to talk
about all of the different things we
could see at the battle now as we all
know the night king is currently south
of the wall and he's slowly making his
way down Westeros as I have said in
videos before the night king will most
likely attack some of the other castles
in the north before he makes it to
Winterfell I think he will do this for
two different reasons one reason is
because the night King will obviously
want to make his army bigger by
attacking those other smaller targets
first the night king can easily add more
soldiers to his army this will also slow
down the night king just long enough for
everyone to get set up in Winterfell
this should keep all of us waiting in
suspense now when it comes to Winterfell
it has been one of the central locations
of the story this house has been here
ever since of the long night ended
roughly 8,000 years ago there is also a
very good chance the night King has a
deep connection to the house in the
books old nan said that she believed the
night King is a stark who very well
could have slept in the very same bed as
Brien Stark I believe the night King has
had his eyes set on taken Winterfell for
a very long time there is even some
evidence that may suggest the crypts of
Winterfell contain either the first
night's king or even the night's queen
now besides the night King's mysterious
connection
to the castle we also know this is where
almost all of the main characters will
be located next season the night king
actor recently sat down for an interview
in during that interview he said we will
find out the night King has a very
specific target next season according to
the actor this is a target that he wants
to kill now we all have our guesses on
who we think this target could be we
have seen the night King and Jon Snow
have two very tense moments in previous
seasons we have also seen Daenerys
Targaryen attack than I came with her
dragons and some fans have always
thought that the birth of the Dragons
could have been what caused the night
king to return as we all know the night
King has already taken one of Danny's
dragons and he did try to kill another
one right when she took off on drug on
so maybe the night king wants to get all
of the dragons but we also know there is
one other character that has a very
close connection to the night king that
character is bran stark as we all know
the night king was able to grab bran
when they were both inside of a vision
inside of the weirwood net when the
night king did this he did leave a mark
on brain Starks arm that allowed the
night king to know the exact location of
bran and that also allowed the night
King to enter that location even if it
was protected by magic now we don't know
for a fact if bran stark still has that
mark on his arm or not the night King
might still be able to find brains exact
location because of that that's just one
of the many reasons why I think bran
Stark is the night Kings target now the
interesting thing is all of these
characters will be in Winterfell at the
same time regardless of which character
the night King once bran stark Jon Snow
and Daenerys Targaryen will all be there
by the end of the first episode so if
any of you were wondering why the night
king wants to attack Winterfell his
motivation could come from some of the
things I just mentioned now let's get
into which characters we know will be
here during the battle as of right now
we know of Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen
Sansa Stark Arya Stark Gendry bran Stark
Samwell Tarly
Tyrion Lannister Davos Seaworth Podrick
Payne Jorah Mormont grey worm and
missandei Gilly and her baby Varys Jaime
Lannister Brienne of Tarth and Sandor
Clegane based on what we saw in the new
trailer these are the characters we
could see where I Winterfell next season
we saw some of them lining up on the
battle
filled some of them were fighting some
of them were making weapons and some of
them were even hiding down in the crypts
of Winterfell that is an insane amount
of characters to be fighting in the same
battle now we also saw Lord Commander
dollar aside tormund Giantsbane and
beric Dondarrion in the trailer it
wasn't entirely clear where these
characters were but I can almost
guarantee they will be fighting in that
battle as well now there are a handful
of other characters that could show up
but I just want to go off of who we know
will be there based on the footage from
the trailer or the article written by
Entertainment Weekly as of right now I
would say it's safe to confirm that
these characters will be there during
the attack now just besides these
characters we know by name there will
also be some rather large armies
fighting here - obviously we know that
Jon Snow's Northern armies will be there
but we also know Danny's armies are
there as well from the trailer we can
see the unsullied getting ready for
battle we can also see some of the
Dothraki soldiers riding on their horses
right behind Jorah Mormont thanks to the
trailer we can also confirm the Knights
of the Vale will be here as well you can
see several other soldiers in formation
right behind Brienne and Podrick this is
already shaping up to be one hell of a
battle just based on who we know will be
there this is like an all-star lineup of
characters unlike anything we have ever
seen before now there are some X factors
I think I should mention although this
is complete speculation we know that
Melisandre said she was heading to
volantis last season but she did tell
Varys she would return one last time
why Melisandre actually went to volantis
is still a mystery but there is a very
good chance she went to go get the fiery
hand a group of slave soldiers from the
red temple of her lure as we all know
Melisandre has always talked about the
darkness coming to take over Westeros
this is something we have heard her
refer to ever since she first appeared
in the show Melisandre has been waiting
for this day for a very long time in
fact the last time she spoke to Jon
Snow's she told him she could help him
defeat the night king Melisandre was
also the one that suggested Daenerys
should meet with Jon Snow and like she
said last season she has brought Ice and
Fire together well now that the night
King has invaded Westeros there is no
way in hell that Melisandre shows up in
Westeros empty-handed
if I were you I would expect to see
Melisandre during the battle in
Winterfell
another x-factor has to do with Jaime
Lannister I don't think he's gonna show
up and Winterfell empty-handed either
not only could he show up with Bronn but
he might also stop at a few places along
the way he could stop at either Riverrun
or even the twins just in case any of
you forgot ed mere talia's Catelyn
Stark's brother
which makes him Sansa Arya in brain
Stark's uncle
now that Walder Frey is no longer in
charge of the twins ed mirror might be
able to get set free Jaime Lannister
could be the one that lets him out and
together they could rally as many
soldiers from the Riverlands as they can
not only would that help during the
fight against the night king but it
could also give Jaime some leverage when
he shows up in Winterfell without any
help from Cersei now I'm already sure
that the Starks will send out some more
Ravens now that the night king is
invading but maybe Jaime does this since
he is already heading in that direction
we also know that Theon Greyjoy is out
there somewhere too now it's hard to say
if he will make it back to Winterfell in
time but he could always show up with
some extra men as well we also cannot
forget about Meera and Helen Reed these
two could be x-factors it's kind of hard
to say how many men they could actually
have at their disposal Howland Reed has
already known to be a mysterious
character but the thing about him that
intrigues me the most is the fact that
he has spent time at the gods eye this
is a very magical location that still
may be inhabited by some of the children
of the forest as well as some of the
green men that guarded
according to old nan the green man right
on elq's and they sometimes even have
antlers now imagine if the reeds were
able to show up with some of the green
men and some of the children of the
forest the children could show up
launching some of their little fireballs
like we've seen them do before however
we did not see any signs of that
happening in the trailer so none of this
extra stuff I mentioned is confirmed as
of right now but I just thought I should
mention it because you never really know
what might happen next season after all
this is said to be one of the greatest
battles and cinematic history now
unfortunately for all of these
characters they have to face one of the
greatest threats Westeros has ever known
now I want to take a look at what the
night King has in his army we don't know
exactly how many dead the night King has
in his army but during the Dragon
it seen last season daenerys targaryen
said she believes the night king had a
hundred thousand whites since Daenerys
Targaryen did get a bird's-eye view of
the night king's army I will take her
word for it another thing we don't know
is how many White Walkers the night King
still has according to Craster he said
that he had 99 sons you have one son
don't you a moment I had my 99th you
ever meet a man with 99 sons now if we
assume that Craster sacrificed all of
those sons then we can assume at one
time there might have been 99 White
Walkers the most amount of White Walkers
we have ever seen at one time is 14 in
total when we saw the night King turn
when a crest her sons into a white
Walker we could see that there were
already 12 white Walker standing behind
the night king then you have to include
the night king himself who is the
baddest white Walker of them all and of
course you have to add the baby the
night King turned into a white Walker
during the scene but there could
potentially be over 90 of em still left
because we have only seen a couple of
them die Samwell Tarly killed one Meera
Reed killed one and John Snow has been
able to kill two of them so far out of
the 99 sons crashed her said he had we
have only seen four of those sons die
which means the night king could have
roughly 95 White Walkers left now
besides the white sand the White Walkers
we also know the night King has giants
in his army at the beginning of season
seven we were able to get a good view of
the night Kings army during that scene
we could see at least three giants
marching with the rest of the soldiers
we have all seen what kind of an
advantage you can have when you have a
giant in your army now imagine if you
had three of them just one of those
giants could open up the gates at
Winterfell to allow the rest of the army
inside another thing we saw in the night
Kings army last season was a snow bear
now we all know that Jorah Mormont was
able to kill the bear when he stabbed it
with the dragonglass dagger but that
might not be the only animal the NIE
King as in his army the night king could
have more bears
direwolves shadowcats and God knows what
else the night king can essentially
resurrect just about anything that died
beyond the wall or anything he comes
across as
he makes his way down a Winterfell the
night Kings army will continue to grow
until someone puts a stop to him and on
top of all of this the knight King now
has a dragon added to his arsenal
since the knight King has control over
Viserion he now has the ability to do
drone strikes wherever the hell he wants
now luckily for all the characters in
Winterfell Daenerys Targaryen still has
two dragons of her own Jon Snow was also
able to get enough dragon glass to arm
just about everyone fighting in the
battle there were some glimpses of this
and the new trailer we could see piles
and piles of dragon glass where Gendry
was working in the forges we could
already see that someone gave Arya Stark
a dragon glass dagger although she does
already have a Valyrian steel dagger
thanks to bran stark danny's unsullied
army is also using new dragon glass
weapons as well
you can see it on the end of their
Spears it even looks like the edges of
their shields are wrapped in dragon
glass too so even though the knight King
may have a very big army that continues
to grow John and Daenerys do have the
right weapons to defeat them now when it
comes to the whites which makes up the
majority of the knight king's army we
have seen three different types of
weapons kill them we know they can be
killed by fire there have been examples
of this dating all the way back to the
first season we also know the whites can
be killed by dragon glass as well Jon
Snow demonstrated this last season at
the dragon pit and thanks to the mission
beyond the wall it now looks like the
whites can be killed by Valyrian steel
too this was the weapon John was using
when he went to capture the white now
when it comes to the White Walkers which
are created by Craster Suns we have only
seen two different types of weapons kill
them we have seen two different White
Walkers get killed by dragon glass
thanks to Samwell Tarly and mirror Reed
then we saw Jon Snow killed two other
way walkers with his Valyrian steel
sword as of right now it doesn't look
like fire can kill the White Walkers
because we have seen them walk right
through fire on a number of different
occasions we have even seen the night
King walk right through the dragon fire
beyond the wall now Daenerys should be
able to kill most of the whites with our
dragons from the sky but in order to
kill the White Walkers and maybe even
the night king they're gonna have to get
up close and personal in order to do
this that is of course unless they were
able to use up
and arrow now as of right now there are
only a handful of Valyrian steel weapons
left as we all know John Snow has a
Valyrian steel sword called Longclaw
Arya Stark has a Valyrian steel dagger
known as the cat's paw
Brienne of Tarth has a Valyrian steel
sword called Oathkeeper given to her by
Jaime Lannister Samwell Tarly took his
family's ancestral Valyrian steel sword
called hearts Bane although now it looks
like Sir Jerome Mormont maybe he's in
that sword during the battle and of
course since Joffrey and Tommen are both
dead Jaime Lannister now has the
Valyrian steel sword what as well since
these are the characters that have the
Valyrian steel weapons we will most
likely see them go up against most of
the White Walkers the faster you can
take out the White Walkers the faster
you can take out all the whites last
season we found out that every time you
kill a white Walker you can also kill
all of the White's he was commanding
that's a very valuable piece of
information if they can somehow get to
the White Walkers are the night king
fast enough then we can start to see
very large groups of whites die
simultaneously the only problem is this
will not be an easy task the episode is
expected to be the longest consecutive
battle sequence ever committed to film
and brings the largest number of major
characters together since the show's
debut this final face-off between the
army of the Dead and the army of the
living is completely unprecedented and
relentless in a mixture of genres even
within the battle there are said to be
sequences built within sequences built
within sequences now the one thing about
this battle that will be very
interesting is the way we get to see it
unfold if you remember the Battle of the
bastards we saw most of the battle
through the eyes of Jon Snow
that was the character we followed
throughout the battle but that will not
be the case for the battle in Winterfell
since there are so many major characters
fighting at the same time the camera
will move around from character to
character during some of the most
intense moments of the battle this will
actually be the very first time we have
seen Arya Stark fight in a battle which
is kind of crazy because we have seen
her training the most the director of
the episode Miguel Sabatini called
Maisie Williams a year before the
filming even begun he told her to start
training for her scenes immediately
because what she will be doing is very
difficult we even got a small taste of
this in the new
trailer it sounds like arias star will
be kicking some major ass during the
battle now it says when the director was
getting ready to start filming the
episode he tried to find a longer battle
sequence in cinema history but it says
he couldn't the closest thing that he
could find was the nearly 40-minute
helms deep sea Jin the Lord of the Rings
which he did study so it sounds like
this will be the longest battle in not
only television history
but cinematic history as well now
another interesting thing they did was
they expanded the Winterfell set Jacob
Anderson who is grey worm in the show
had said the Winterfell set is unlike
anything I have ever seen in my life
you can walk into rooms and crossing the
tunnels and find yourself in another
part of the castle it's really immersive
especially when there is haze and snow
and people running around you can get
genuinely lost there were a few moments
where I forgot it wasn't real which is
bizarre from what we can see in the new
trailer it looks like the battle will be
absolutely insane there will be dead
bodies littered across the entire
battlefield there will be dragons
fighting it out in the sky with the
heroes of the battle defending the
castle on the ground
visibility should be at a minimum not
only is this battle taking place at
night but it's also snowing and there
will be smoke everywhere due to all the
fires since there are dragons in this
battle and we know fire kills the lights
we can almost guarantee Winterfell will
be burnt how bad it will be burnt is
still anyone's guess but we can see
there is fire all across the entire set
with the night king having a dragon in
the sky and roughly a hundred thousand
White's fighting on the ground and
giants most likely knocking down the
gates our main characters will not be
able to hold them off forever
the army of the Dead will eventually
make it up over the castle walls and
even into the castle where we see them
chasing Arya Stark when you have this
many main characters fighting in the
same battle at the same time you can
pretty much guarantee that some of our
beloved heroes will lay dead in the snow
by the time the smoke clears
when Entertainment Weekly wrote this a
big cover story about the final season
of Game of Thrones they started it off
by talking about the aftermath of the
battle in Winterfell I want to end this
video by telling you what it says the
great battle is over the snowy ground is
streaked with blood beloved heroes
lay dead outside of the castle gates
Winterfell is quiet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]